her face hangs on school railings her
tragedy has sparked a teacher's revolt
here at this school in Newbury just a
few miles from where Ruth Perry took her
life staff filed out in silent
solidarity
Ruth's family say she killed herself as
a direct result of a critical inspection
by ofsted the school's regulator
Liz a former teacher at Ruth's school
told us the inspection didn't reflect
reality
were not leaving
primary teachers were there for years
and years and years under Ruth's
headship and they were happy there and
they had a dedicated and caring and
expert her teacher and this is just
devastating and this is why we're here
for Ruth today
and another Community was left
devastated in 2015 when Carol Woodward
killed herself after ofsted downgraded
her school police told her inquest the
inspection was fair but its timing
during exams had contributed to immense
pressure on her over the phone Carol's
husband Roger told me about the impact
it had even though it was sort of six to
seven years ago it's almost as though it
was yesterday ofsted just put schools
under tremendous amount of pressure and
the head teacher obviously Bears the
brunt of it and in this sort of latest
scenario where she's being criticized
and like Carol said she she sort of felt
as of this the whole school had been let
down one concern in schools is the
grading system used by ofsted something
that was scrapped in Wales last year
after a review schools are very very
complex organizations so a grade is is
attempting to give a a kind of one word
judgment about a very complex
organization
the government said that inspections are
important for holding schools to account
the question is at what cost to teachers
Matthew Thompson Sky News Newbury